[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
happy Thursday everybody
[Music]
yeah almost Friday it's a fun day too
so it's one of those special nights for
us when we let you the audience choose
the monologue topic nobody else does
this it's a segment that we call
the audience decides the story
kind of redundant at this point I mean I
I'd already said that but the rules are
this I tell you two topics and the
stronger clap determines which story
we're going to choose
FYI this is exactly how my parents
determined who got fed at dinner
now
it's okay the first story the inflation
rate as you know is a critical measure
of an economy's Health therefore
understanding how it correlates to other
economic measures in a stable economy
might help us comprehend these
inflationary Cycles
all right so the second topic what the
hell is up with the Trans High School
shop teacher in Canada with giant
inflatable boots wait don't tell
you guys can't follow the rules we're
gonna have to do it all over again
all right so let's compare the story one
on inflation
[Applause]
you don't count Tyrus
story two also on inflation
[Music]
all right settle down you perverts
so the audience decides giant breasts
wins by a nipple
I admit the contest was a bust
but that means it's time for
if it happens up there we report down
here you're watching gazumba gate Canada
2023
week 13.
man this story is getting bigger and
bouncier
and like Dagan's old report cards
there's a lot of D's
so as a favorite of people who just
tuned in for the first time here's a
quick recap
she what's what's a he began identifying
as female last year and started wearing
massive prosthetic breasts to class the
school board still stands behind the
teacher no other choice in the unlikely
event of a water emergency landing your
shop teacher can be used as a flotation
device we're the only show that keeps
diligent tabs on the Ontario transgender
teacher with the oversized prosthetic
breasts and saucer-sized nipples is this
truly a trans teacher or is it a prank
that's gotten way out of hand how about
a little Common Sense women don't even
look like that in my dreams the shop
teacher was recently pictured in all her
immense booberry skydiving
exactly so what happened what's happened
since then well parents of the Oakville
Trafalgar high school students have
hired a lawyer to begin legal
proceedings against the district school
board they're frustrated with the
board's lack of transparency unlike the
teacher's sweater
and they're fearful of the growing
threats of violence against the school
over the overt sexual attire of a
transgender teacher so they took action
students First Ontario that's the group
numbering in the hundreds said parents
have followed board protocol initially
taking their concerns to school
administration and the board and
directly to their trustees but the board
stands by its official statement in
response to the teacher's large
prosthetic and braless breasts
as always the board quote is committed
to establishing and maintaining a safe
caring inclusive Equitable and welcoming
learning and working environment for all
students and staff
and oh yeah did we mention we love Giant
I don't think that was in there
students are also being threatened with
suspension if they photograph the
teacher that's interesting
and yet here we are the only show
covering this surreal thought-provoking
story
and why is it because I'm obsessed
no maybe I just need to get this off my
chest
you see a parent at this school is in a
no-win situation it's like a meeting
where the only two empty seats are on
either side of Brian Kilmeade
lose lose
[Music]
you can just see him sitting there
trans teacher is either trolling the
school or demanding protection for a
fetish masquerading as a non-binary
trait but if that costume is then
welcomed why not any Behavior what stops
a teacher from putting a giant
prosthetic penis in their pants don't
think I haven't thought of that
you didn't know this but I teach intro
to twerking at the local Junior College
and I need all the help I can get
so you can take your private fetish
public and as long as you portray
yourself as a target of hate it works
what if the principle is a dominatrix
kids will have to take their whipping or
get called a bigot which will mean more
whipping
now what if we just ignored this story
well then we allow the non-science of
gender activism to unleash public
fetishism on all of us the inmates will
be running the Asylum and it will look
that way with all the bondage I mean
what if you have a fetish what keeps you
from sharing it at work telling Geraldo
to cover up that thong would get me
called to HR
Ducey would turn Fox and Friends into a
Furry Convention
and what of the shop teacher you'd think
the whirling razor sharp teeth of a
table saw would be enough of a deterrent
to keep mammary glands McGee from the
classroom
no not at all what if my fetish is
flashing it's not much different than a
man slapping on giant breasts with
nipples the size of frozen pizza
so why can't I wander the halls in an
open robe if that expresses my true self
it's true I always wanted to be Charlie
Rose
[Applause]
welcome
tonight's guests he has five daughters
and high blood pressure American
conservative Union chairman match
[Applause]
she's got the eye of the tiger in a jar
on her desk co-host of the bottom line
congratulations starting January 23rd on
Fox Business David McDowell
like bathroom towels you'll always find
her hung over in the shower
upstairs
finally he has no clue what a ladder is
my Master's idea again the nwa's World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
so Matt I think this might be the first
time you're on the show when I've
covered this topic is that true yes but
your wife has been on me many times
she's talked about this she's talked
about it a number of times and you
wouldn't believe her opinions on it are
quite shocking if you ask me we won't
get into that how do you assess or grade
my reporting so far or analysis on this
topic this is not uh this is not shown
up on any show as far as I know anywhere
you know I have one of those it's called
a belly and the uh and all I can think
of is what would have happened if Dr
fauci had become a plastic surgeon
I also am a little embarrassed because
my pastor said he loved to watch me on
gutfelding here we are
we had to start here but don't you think
that there is like a slippery slope and
I'm not talking about her
but you know what I mean it's like if
this if if if you can't stand up to
something that is obviously fetishistic
then anything can go we have Unleashed
uh we have made Heroes of people who
seem to be struggling uh in their lives
and it seems to be front and center in
our classrooms yeah and I think a lot of
Americans find it rather repugnant it's
good to mock it but after the mockery we
got to make this stuff stop like go live
your life it's fine but don't uh pollute
the minds of yeah you can dress anywhere
you want but this is like you know there
are kids there and but and uh I'm gonna
keep covering this story until it's you
know I'll just keep covering it
congratulations Dagan
thank you very good
it's got a new no premiering on Fox
Business called the bottom line is that
correct bottom line thank you yes was
Sean Duffy thank you Sean Duffy now
who's that Rachel Campos Duffy's husband
we all know who Sean Duffy is he's got
like 700 kids yes he does
he's like that Eight is Enough guy right
yeah it has so the kids are threatened
with suspension if they take a picture
of the teacher yet the teacher can
basically who is looking for attention
can be there does that make sense uh no
and all of the kids in the school and
even the teachers who have to be upset
about this have a way to fight back
everybody needs to start wearing super
tight jeans like Dwight Yoakam tight and
they all need to start wearing
ginormous prosthetic scrotums
like and it doesn't have to be something
you buy on the internet but like you
what you made homemade
yeah like grow them in your garden
digging like ball up a giant sweatshirt
and shove it in your jeans look like
look like you got a big old possum in
your pants
or like a wombat in your britches but
everybody needs to be walking around
like they are very uh like yes
uncomfortable we can't show it everybody
everybody in the entire school because
it will descend into chaos yes the kids
won't be able to sit for more than like
a couple of minutes because they got a
giant scrotum in their pants as big as
that Z cup prosthetic and it's not a d
it's a z and it costs about 760 Canadian
dollars because I looked on Etsy
I digress but again you will never
nobody will ever be able to play sports
you can't with a big old again wombat
your britches you can't run to first
base digging uh you'll have to stop
school yeah stop
um
so this is from Hollywood Reporter that
fox has decided to shelve the bottom
line
now it's being replaced with something
called the Duffy Zone
by me
I don't know who to go to next because I
know both of you despise this topic
so I'm take it away cat I need time but
no but cat you got it like you know
there are a lot of things I don't like
to talk about but I think there's a good
this is a philosophical question
right
okay when you say you're the only person
covering this you really are the only
yes person and it's so fascinating
because that's a philosophical study to
me because there's nobody that you're
doing this verses yeah there's like Don
lemon's not opening his little Morning
Show like the transphobia has gone too
far at Fox News and then showing you
talking about this maybe he should
nobody there are people who you know
live to call out other people for
transphobia but this they're like
silent yeah nothing to say nobody nobody
thinks this is like normal or cool
except for apparently some people in
Canada but Canada is not real no so here
I mean nobody thinks that like we have
to blur it out yes and like there's no
and they can't figure it out at school
exactly they can't we she can't they
can't have a big they should cut out
these giant things of something blurry
and tape it to the nipples they walk
around they're like big giant plates of
blurriness
like satellite dishes Tyrus I got the
gist yeah gosh I heard you went bowling
last night how was that yeah it was
great phenomenal yeah anything's
anything spherical you're going to want
to talk about it I'm going to end up
talking about Generation Z over there
listen I I was ready to talk about
economics tonight shame on all of you
and unfortunately Dagan uh you gotta run
longer wider strides helps a bag of your
pants also but
um unfortunately oh I have to draw you a
picture you want me to do it get to the
point all right
unfortunately because you would be
identifying as a man you would have been
suspended as soon as you walked in the
door where are the feminists on this why
is it that when a man decides to
transition to get attention they always
super sexualify what it is to be a woman
wearing a tight skirt and having your
nipples showing is not what it is to be
a woman right it is what it is to be a
fantasy of a man who watches too much
porn but everyone is treating this with
gloves well I would wear gloves too but
they're not calling her out on her
inappropriateness so the needs of the
fetish yeah is more important than the
needs of the children in the community
because of the virtue signaling when
that by definition has nothing to do
with Womanhood there you go
that's why we do these stories act okay
all right I just I'm imagining like if
you're a parent and your kid's not doing
well in shop class and you have to go
like talk to this teacher okay my kids
you just take the F you just take the F
and move on yeah all right now we must
move on hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else